and this is the one there's only six
players allowed and you can try and jump
in quickly crown stars four four zero
three nine I'm waiting for five other
opponents these are round robins there
will be five games played in this one
and I am waiting for players to track
this down and enter so far one uhq has
entered waiting on another Xan thoria is
another I'm the best and Andrew G Meier
there was an experience level of 30
required for this one anyhow this is the
group that will be playing I will be
playing against these guys five rounds
there are there is another player
somewhere they didn't show up but anyhow
crown stars this is Fisher a random time
okay I just ready to double the points
let us see what is unprotected nothing I
like this is a start so let's go with
the controlling one of these four center
squares my rook is able to see my bishop
is able to see my knight probably wants
to get out of the corner
it's my opponent going to play the
copycat game I'm not sure what I want to
do with my beep on mmm actually I could
grab this pun that night was the only
one that was defending it I also might
want to run back home before he
potentially gets trapped with g6
or better yet let's not run home and
let's stay opposite this Queen that has
to be a bit uncomfortable as pawn can't
move now and I need some more
development in my is my opponent going
to be able to get in this advance I'm
not so sure about
I was thinking about maybe something
like b4 but I do have to be cautious
about the potential for Bishop a4 so I
think I like this better just a single
square so my queen could see clearly and
okay I can do this I can move my knight
in order to Castle kingside
what am i needing to do I have to move
my knight and Bishop before I could
Castle kingside I think I just get my
knight out first my opponent cannot
Castle kingside since they move that
rook from g8 to f8 LightSquared Bishop
Tsar being challenged I think I just
still move forward with more progress
more development my dark square bishop
would come out and I was gonna capture
with my knight but I think capturing
with my pawn is better yeah I think I
start getting kicked around with this F
pawn push if I take with my knight and I
really don't I I see this as a nice
support point now a dark square bishop I
believe belongs right here my knight is
here to watch over this pawn my opponent
has about a 1 minute lead I just want to
Castle kingside next this is an open
file so maybe actually I don't want to
castle so fast there let me get my clean
up I'm gonna I'm gonna hold off on that
my opponent could queenside castle pick
up that King and drop it on that rook we
centralized my knight I'm gonna leave my
options open a bit I could have taken
this I don't know if I really want to
give up my darks for a bishop but to be
honest I just didn't see it initially
yeah maybe I could pile up on it more
Knight f5 and I'll take with my knight I
can always play e3 this is another
reason I went with Knight d5 not only is
it a good post but if the knight ever
becomes annoying on d4 kick it away at
the e3 I'm gonna do similar I don't want
to get into an opposite sides castling
situation maybe this is good just to
keep the knight out of here
both nights out of here and although
this has a lot of support for it right
now Knight to e5
now 95 i jot drops this pun I'm gonna
pre-meal this just right and pick off
that pine and run back now he can't be
dislodged there is no palm push to kick
him away so he's got to go to b8 he's
crazy if he goes to d7 he's crazy
it's official this bishop is also he's
having a rough day that Bishop is
definitely having a rough day
actually if I knew the king was gonna
play here I might have wanted to go
elsewhere like f5 put pressure on d6 b7
I don't think that there's a good
solution here there's no there's no
weaknesses that black could be jumping
into weaknesses no holes and that's a
fork one of these nights we'll be out of
here and he's the one and now there are
deadly discoveries I don't know if that
one was best but gonna go with it
Knights are jumping in this pond could
fall he is falling
there's also Queen check which is going
to be brutal or a knight check which is
gonna be brutal cuz my Queen has this
die and I'll cut off oh okay I was still
imagining my Queen being on this square
I thought that that exchange would have
come okay we have resignation
good game uhq there are other games
going on right now this is the one that
has not yet finished let's see who wins
this one it's looking like black is
gonna win black is doing well at the
time and with the position very well on
both these are not what this is now war
zone this is just five around er five
round tournament
okay so the mopping up phase a new queen
is on the scene the bishop is dead watch
out for steel me that's the only thing
to watch out for no steel me and then
that's gonna be a boom boom boom boom
that'll do it right what is going on
Queen check stepladder in this direction
there we go the old stepladder walk the
dog trick yo-yo fans here
alright that's game over let's close out
of that mine is gonna start up round two
the leaders who won three ones Andrew oh
man okay Andrew G Mayer
what's up protected this guy and he's
accessible the a B G and H pawns are
accessible after the first move to being
captured so as soon as the pond rules I
have to do something about this guy as
soon as my partner was my opponent
probably has to do something about that
guy my opponent should probably move
quick to do they disconnect no they
didn't they were like wait I'm gonna
listen in on this stream a little bit I
want to gain a little more insight are
they using stream tactics against me
stream tactics or scare tactics which of
the two that's not too scary of the move
although wait the knight can maybe go to
one of these two I'm not afraid of that
Emily okay let's plant upon in the
center I guess I could now look to
reinforce this pond if there's more fire
being placed on it my knight could play
to d6 and I these two support points
similar to how this Knight is behind the
power
like you get my night behind the pond
and I think I want to do that right away
maybe stop both efore and c4 from coming
into play where does this night want to
be maybe he could get to a 4-h 4-h for
it might be a good spot or maybe get to
this square there's no particular square
right now that I could really rely upon
I don't know if I want to do similar
with my Jeep um because then the knight
could get to one of these two a bit
easier this square in particular this
room it could be very annoying and I
think I'm gonna keep the knight out of
there and now actually something that
maybe I should have considered right
from the beginning I was seeing more of
the Queen being able to get to this
point but what about a knight he's
looking to get to either one of these
and then put pressure on this pawn
however my knight is there to watch over
it so let's do this my queen is hitting
this pawn so the knight cannot yet move
he has a job and that is to watch over
this pawn however why did I just look
into this maybe I should just be doing
that move let's get him out now I could
at least Castle and have my king then
defend this pawn so if there I'm gonna
do right now how do you defend against
this bishop retreat King move it's very
awkward is it not very awkward to have
to defend against the weakest point
right in a regular chess game they said
that that weakest point is f2 and f7 but
with these Fischer randoms you have to
reassess your enough to have to think
much different don't you okay so I'm
pressing forward and Center I'm open to
this position opening up if he does have
pressure on him I am going to just
Castle queenside and my rook will be
there to watch over that however I like
taking this Knight much better and now
press forward and the idea here is to is
well actually doing this is now not good
because my queen could be taking this
pawn I want to still castle in this
direction this file is going to open up
my life square bishop is the
that needs the most work ideally I'd
like to get him right here on f3 he's
threatening this pond and that was
missed this is now taken with cheque and
this is going to crumble fast the Queen
is hit I probably shouldn't have even
done that she could have played here to
give check I don't want this pawn to go
any further I could take it but I don't
want to allow this file to open up I'm
just gonna reposition I don't have to go
after material in such a position now my
knight is here to get this retreat and
stop this pond from moving any further I
also have a fork that I should have run
with right away everything is now hit
clean rook rook 14 seconds remaining as
well I thought actually I might get
trapped with Bishop here but I do have
Queen takes pawn this Queen is out of
play right now in a big way pac-man mode
time everything is falling open up the
position open up that position okay they
resigned
good game Andrew G let's close out of
that and see what else is going on in
this tournament are those other two
beams still going on this is a battle
this is a battle here thirty two seconds
for white who is up a queen this is
actually not a battle white should be
winning this one right this is not too
big of a time deficit to make up even if
the knight defends with ninety five I
think Knight takes here would have been
available it's still available Queen
taking here and there's got to be some
fork seeing how both the knight and
Bishop would be unprotected and the king
is just completely naked of defenders
Queen position on f5 not so fast that
Knight is there to defend twenty seconds
remaining twenty to forty time wise
worked out for the tricky Knights the
night is hit as soon as he's gone
Oh we just have resignation okay
resignation their leaders two guys with
two Zhan thoria
this is the leader this is a big game my
clock is ticking what do I do what is
unprotected
a - and that's pretty much it so what
does this mean how do I want to start
the Bishop's are in their ideal
positions or their yeah regular
positions what do I do upon push here I
like this
followed up with 9c3 like in English
what else c4 Knight c3 let's get my
knight in there right away and I think I
do
hmm let's try this I have my night
watching over c2 for a second I was
thinking night before to c2 as a threat
it's really not we might have this
copycat game otherwise I could establish
a nice Center and one that I could
reinforce with the knight see - okay now
it's pretty prevented maybe I should be
doing something you let my queen out I'm
gonna do this cuz now I have something
to maybe bite at with my HP and I could
scoop my clean up now keep in mind one
of the things that would keep me from
maybe going two steps with my palm like
this is if these Black Knights were a
bit closer in this section of the board
but I don't really see it being too
annoying to my queen who wants to just
really bump up a square so I'm one step
closer to getting developed on this side
of the board I don't want to go here so
let's try here my knight can be taken I
can't move this pawn though I can't move
my knight either this is a bit awkward
what if the knight place here I play
Bishop e2 the knight place here then
there is not direct pressure on this and
that might give me an opportunity to
move my knight or my pawn or pushed
forward in the center if Bishop here to
attack my queen I don't know if I want
to do f4 because that would weaken this
square so what do I do
wait a second this is weakened what
about Knight here right now looking for
a knight check we drop this pawn but
maybe I could get this one
got to be good if I could get this check
in in a 960 game right I'm gonna go for
it giving up a pond just to get sub
pressure a nice night on d6 I still want
to get Castle down I need some more
coordination here I also don't think I
capture if Bishop takes pawn I don't
think I take the bishop because the
queen is gonna be very annoying hitting
at my night that's unprotected so I
think I'd give just an immediate check
and I just develop my Bishop next I
guess I could have considered taking
this pond but I like this check better
oh you know what I'm in trouble
was not expecting that King move okay
time to regroup because Bishop here is a
threat I can't do this the King takes
the knight I gotta take this yeah I'm
gonna take that and try and work on the
fact that the King is um castled can I
make this work we're gonna see about
that
sacking Abbey pun for some attack
against this king who is now homeless
okay I think I need to do this it does
weaken this square but you know what I
want to get the move back that's my
number one job right now so I'm gonna
castle I have this covered I want to
maybe even sack another pond or or
Bishop eight free I like Bishop eight
three there's a pin pawn push pawn push
again I think that this is right takes I
place c5 and then really bust open this
position I think I get this pawn back
get this pawn back what is this Knight
gonna go then I could be playing here
okay that is with check and I think I
take with my pawn I'm gonna go with to
my pond my bishop wants to do something
if the knight place here I think I want
to get rid of that night as soon as
possible
I have this covered three times maybe
take up that night okay now we have this
I'm gonna go here to take out the night
the night is also in a pin these bishops
are brood
very brutal you can't even kick it away
cuz I take this night I think I just
back all the way up I'm gonna take here
first and then back up I don't want to
allow that take so I have this covered
twice my queen wants to do something
else then just sit in the corner
let's go away right here
if 94 Bishop here have this King these
guys are not playing the game yet my
queen is hitting this pawn the night is
probably going to play here rook to e1
they're down on time less than 20
seconds Queen takes pawn you have to
defend that I'm opposite the King still
struggling to get active Queen here
looking for now b8 the rook left that
back reg possibilities for maybe then
taking out this Knight
I think this is the number one guy get
rid of him and then potential pawn push
now I think everything is going to be
blown open less than 10 seconds my
knight is very strong I'm just going to
take this and now push open it up here
there's also checks 5 seconds remaining
I could just trade down at this point
and abandon the idea of going for an
attack and instead just when I'm telling
him really no time
rooks are falling no time no stalemates
back to tournament who my opponent was
rattling off those moves right at the
end right there that was like a new mode
right there
superfast bullet mode ok waiting for
Round four all games are finished for
round three okay I'm the best all right
what's unprotected it's my first thought
nothing okay
I think I like I think I like this is a
start
Knight f3 castling is going to be quite
easy in this one alright right out okay
this is like a Sicilian structure but
what's this night going to do now big
castle and I think I might want to go
with okay this is week I would really
like to do this but the Queen is there
to watch out for it I'm gonna try this
build a center my opponent is neglecting
the center so what what's the follow-up
after you do that once you have a nice
Center what are some things you could
then look forward to doing that's like
you hear that phrase a lot right yeah
you want to control the center why
well can you how can you then put it to
work what sort of advantage could that
translate into is maybe another way to
look at it once you have this Center you
could then look forward to pressing
forward and gaining space which is what
I'm going to do right now now this
Knight has to find a new home and I
don't know that there's a good home also
now that I have a space advantage
ideally I'd like to avoid exchanges
going here or here is dropping material
I'm gonna pick up the material is there
something better than taking this pawn
maybe I should take the knight and
compromise this pawn structure I don't
see that as being so great I like my
bishop right where it's at when you pick
up that pun what am I not doing yet what
pieces are not working this rook is not
working and my bishop wants to be on e -
maybe I should have done that and move
sooner put pressure on this pawn I could
take this Knight no I was saying as soon
as this pawn pushes maybe I could take
the knight I don't want to do that
though this is actually a bit
inconvenient but inconvenient this pawn
has hit three times defended once that's
difficult
why didn't I consider that
ticular pom plush okay well I'm gonna be
dropping that pun I think where am I
I could do tonight here for a second the
core there is no counter tacking move
with Queenie five I'm watching over that
my night is not my night cannot rely
upon this square it's gonna be kicked
soon so maybe the other idea behind
doing this night move is so that I can
now play pawn push and reinforced my
Center it does open up this diagonal
however but I think I have a convenient
response Bishop here I defend okay my
knight has to go to the edge for just a
moment I will be looking to at the
earliest moment reposition my knight my
queen there's no way my queen can be
kicked away I'm down to a minute these
are only three minute games I want to
get my rooks connected if there's my
rook is challenge I'm gonna play Bishop
to e2 whoa okay I'm gonna work again
trying to make this bishop bad I'd love
to get my knight right here that's where
he wants to be and this Knight can't
find a good spot let me get more
development in my rooks are connected
I'm hitting this pawn but it's not good
to be taken because the bishop takes and
I'm in a pin I'm losing a piece let me
get my knight right here watch out for
that d6 square I was looking to blockade
that's interesting lemon I'm gonna know
now I'm gonna do this f3 is very
weakened and that is a giant giant fork
I'm not gonna take I'm not gonna take
the Queen though I don't want to deal
with that sort of stuff I'm still just
up a piece right here this is still be I
think okay let me just come all the way
back here or I should have done that
okay I gotta watch out for that night
that's a reason I should have played
here instead now I have to deal with
this night for even a second that's
something to certainly avoid I could
take that Knight now 34 seconds there's
got to be made very soon Queen here
Queen check
no time for me 30 well sometime 34
seconds take with my queen I don't want
to open up this file I could give checks
pawn push exchange Queens let me get
that here I'm threatening me in one rig
up and over main to threat not a good
defense the brook has to come over most
likely they resigned okay
good game I think there's one more one
more
waiting for round five the last round
yes this is the last round
Pond Center okay what do we have
what's unprotected quickly quickly
quickly nothing is unprotected but this
is certainly very sensitive I like this
as a start my Bishop's when they're
positioned in this way do not have to
move in order to develop a good rule of
thumb I believe they do not have to move
in order to develop to be having an
influence in the game so I'll be looking
for g6 okay now that I'm gonna take the
Queen could potentially get very active
but I have a knight here with tempo can
maybe be a bit awkward
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna still do this
can be taken but my queen is around to
defend like this Queen if she does stuff
like if I'm in a pin soon I could play
Queen c7 to break it such as right now
and I really would like to get the
Queen's off the board
oh especially with this night getting
ready to jump into this square oh I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble I think no I
think I have to offer Queen exchange if
I play here but we got Knight c4 and
then it jumps into this square but I
actually could defend that barely barely
my knight is there in time I think I
have everything right I want to be able
to move this I can't though the Queen is
very annoying to me right now I'm in
trouble I'm in big trouble
big trouble this night needs to go but
then there's a night here I have to stop
this oh man I feel like I'm dead oh I
have to do a pond push maybe oh man oh
you know what I could do you know I have
to do you don't have to make up your
mind what are you talking about I need
to get rid of a piece here and then
Castle kingside I could sneak my king
away as soon as my bishop moves like a
Castle kingside
he jumps right over here real quick
that's what I need a quick castling
maneuver oh okay
he's got to go and he's got to get out
of there and I want to kick the knight
out next before it's too late
yes before it's too late there was ready
queenside castle and the queen and night
would be converging on this square now I
think before this move is played in the
position is able to open up I need to
clamp down on this square also I don't
have a light square bishop around so
ideally I don't want my opponents to be
cracking at the pawns that are on light
squares now I'm ready to queen King side
castle I could queenside castle but I
want to go Kings side and then I'm able
to push this pot with tempo although
when I do King side castle my night is
back into a pin and there we go I am
castled and my rook on F maybe wanted to
go to c8 I could also look into b5 I
think things are back to now being under
control I want my bishop to see my
opponent can now King side castle and
now I want to clamp down on the c4
advance this Knight is kind of stuck
it's reminding me of a sveshnikov let's
jump in now here to c4 I can also look
at these efore squares the Queen is
running short on squares and my Bishop
is maybe wanting to get here to look to
trap her or something oh the night's
gonna play here and hit this pawn that's
inconvenient to have my King do
something
that's actually a bit scary to do that
rook here and there's maybe sax on this
square you know let's have my rook
defend this pawn that's better
this could get very violent yeah okay
yeah we're having this aren't we yes we
are yes we are aren't we I shouldn't
have allowed that okay I don't want my
queen tether to the defense of that
Knight um okay my King is sneaking out
I'm not really a big fan of having my
king like this so scary time it's a
scary time for my king but I think I'm
able to still defend my opponent has
something else to say about that thought
let me let me back up run out of harm's
way
pawn push Bishop back I think I want to
do bishop here no matter what
and that's sure less than 40 seconds
okay now my king can come over here if
he needs to
Queen exchange I'm almost always a fan
of that um grab a pun is that okay oh
man my knight is hit is this okay
the rook is gonna go after this pound I
think I'm gonna play pin Bishop back and
then play my king here and the rook will
be out of play
unless that move is played okay now I
can do this since there's no pressure on
my knight get my other night over here
my rook here but not so fast I want to
do this first tricky Knights vs. rooks
battle I'm still looking for outpost for
my Knights okay I'm gonna do this the
rooks gonna double here this is like the
new 7th rank for white but I'm there in
time to just stay coordinated I wanted
an open file for my rook and now I can
maybe sneak in a tricky fork looking for
a tricky fork or okay let's sneak my
King over King position it's this rook
going to do okay now this rook can't go
too far away Forks just gonna blocks
force family fork everything is hit fork
more Forks around the corner the Knights
are staying coordinated
remove that I thought they were gonna
maybe another fork those tricky nights
everybody gets hit with those tricky
tricky Forks
okay back to tournament and the
tournament is complete confetti land all
right let's go back leaders this was the
final standings oh I didn't mean to do
that
what did I just click on I don't know
when I clicked on the games or something
oh I clicked on that information button
five four three one and a half one and a
half zero Sam theory upon center Andrew
G Meier I'm the best and you HQ good
games all that was different